Peter Capaldi you've done you you've
done some very dangerous things over the
years
didn't you wasn't quite recently you had
an injury yes I was in the three
musketeers such as you know it's lots of
sword fight and it's they ate you know
and guys are jumping off horses and
hitting each other and everyone had kind
of broken shoulder blades and stuff at
that and I played Cardinal Richelieu who
was an old waspish and I had to grab a
lady and give her into trouble and throw
her against the wall and as I was doing
it I suddenly sort of internally
screamed with agony and looked down and
my thumb was caught in her frock this
made me McCoy I looked and my thumb was
on back to front back into place really
so and to this day I can't open a packet
of crisps you're looking great
used to be much heavier
talking off finger injuries at with the
going through pictures pictures before
the show we found my pinky Meryl Streep
has just gone tell me I did a back on
accent she's look at that she's that I
had it rebuilt
I had injured it so many times playing
football American football yeah but it
is fine now but it's like a gummy bear
in there like a little piece of rubber
candy something so what was that thing I
went up for a pass playing American
football and dislocated it and it's
happened so many times over the years
that if I just open my hand like that it
would pop that far in films that they
have to like shoot oh no kids no I'm
constantly you could probably see me
another film just going in I was always
fixing it when my kids were young they
would ask me daddy could you show my
friends the magic finger
[Laughter]
no you went there I didn't do it no I
didn't do like this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and didn't you have to pretend not to
know how to use the TARDIS when you got
the part
whereas people try to explain to you how
to do it well everybody see they do all
this stuff that you've just read out
they didn't know so I go on the same
guys saying what you